The Joe Rogan experience
plan on having any debates with
people that oppose these ideas.
Um, well it was interesting on
your very show, Joe to yeah,
to have the debate that
involved, uh, Michael Shermer,
who's the editor of the
skeptic magazine and, um,
some colleague of his who came in on
line who I got a bit annoyed with,
um, and, um, myself and, uh,
my great friend and colleague,
the genius, Randall
Carlson, uh, and, and, um,
I felt that that was a very useful debate.
Um,
I felt that it's possibly the first
time that those of us on the alternative
side of the argument about history where
we're given an opportunity really to
put our evidence forward and, and
to confront so-called skeptics. Uh,
well, it's so cold. That's
what he calls himself,
Michael Shermer with this evidence. And
you are, obviously I'm biased, but I,
I don't feel that he fielded
the situation particularly well.
I don't think mainstream archeology
came out of that looking really good.
I think it came out of that looking rather
ignorant and uh, and, and uninformed,
uh, and, and a man like Michael
Shermer who is a professional skeptic,
uh, cannot begin to match the knowledge
of a man like Randall Carlson who has
devoted his whole life to walking the
walk of the geology of the end of the ice
age in, in, in North America. And
that showed on, on, on that debate.
So I think the debate was worth doing a,
I think it showed that the alternative
side isn't just wishy washy stuff out
there on the fringes of things that there
are those of us working in this field
who are using really solid
information and who are,
who our project is to rewrite history.
And we're not going to do
that with slight information.
It has to be solid information. I think
we had the opportunity on your show to,
to say that, that, that
solid information is there.
I'm not claiming it was a complete
victory for the alternative side.
Michael Shermer is a smart guy and he
put forward some good arguments to,
and there were constructive
aspects of that debate, which I,
which I appreciate it.
I'd like to see much more engagement
and much more positive approach.
I wish the skeptics welcome
to their skepticism,
but I wish they'd be less hateful,
less less full of derision, less,
less despising. Well, there's sort
of defensive with their ideas and,
and so and so defensive with their
ideas when the possibility is there for,
for a constructive debate.
You know,
what's interesting to me is that as this
evidence piles up and it seems to be
continuing to pile up as more like the,
the,
these impact sites and more of this,
uh,
ancient civilization
material gets unearthed.
It's almost insurmountable.
Yeah. It's almost, and this is how,
this is how paradigms shift. I mean,
everybody's familiar with the concept
of a paradigm shift and there's a book
called the structure of scientific
revolutions by Thomas Kuhn,
which outlines what a paradigm shift is,
where an established model in some
discipline of science that has been in
control of people's thinking for a very
long time suddenly falls apart and it
doesn't fall apart.
Suddenly what happens is that there's
an accumulation of evidence which that
model cannot explain.
That paradigm cannot explain it.
It seemed like a great
paradigm at one point,
but then it doesn't explain this
and then it doesn't explain like,
like the paradigm that says
that Megalithic architecture
is only 6,000 years old
and that the first megalithic architecture
was in Multa that can't explain the
massive megalithic site of good Beckley
Tepi in Turkey 5,500 years before that.
It's evidence like that the slow
accumulation of evidence that the existing
system cannot explain that adventure
will point no matter how strongly the
advocates of the existing
system hold on to it,
no matter how determined
they are in their defense,
no matter what dirty tricks they may
choose to deploy to undermine their
opponents,
sooner or later,
the evidence overwhelms them and the
paradigm goes down and you have a new way
of thinking and that that
is the story of science.
And it is a story that I think,
I think we're at a tipping point in our
understanding of the past of the human
species.
I am not saying that I am 100% right.
I believe that what I'm doing that's
worthwhile is I'm asking questions about
the past that haven't been asked enough.
I'm putting archeologists on the spot and,
and demanding that they
explain themselves. I don't,
I don't claim that I am right.
I'm offering an alternative theory.
And my objective is to get
people to think for themselves,
to think about this stuff and not to
accept, uh, the voice of authority as the,
as the sole, uh, medium of truth.
That's, that's what I've tried to do.
Have you had,
uh,
any archeologist review any of this
work and change their opinions? No.
No I haven't. But what I, what
I have found, uh, and I've,
I've found it interestingly during the
research trips for America before, uh,
is a younger generation of
archeologists who are in the field. Um,
and they are quite different from the
older generation of archaeologists who are
running the whole scene
25 years ago or now.
We have a very different
younger generation,
the younger generation that has been
exposed to open minded thinking, um,
that has been exposed to the Internet.
That itself as part of the general
pattern of the younger generation is
suspicious of authority. I'm meeting
young archeologists on sites. For example,
I met a couple of really
amazing young minds, uh,
on a site called Blackwater
draw, uh, in, um, uh,
Arizona, New Mexico, where, where
the one of the first Clovis sites,
the young archeologist I met there
were incredibly open minded and,
and really willing to
consider extraordinary
possibilities about the past and
privately admitted to me that
they'd read my books. Well,
that's where I get the hope.
I get the hope in this young generation
that is growing up with the Internet
that does understand that there's a lot
more out there than just what they're
being taught in schools.
Yes. Yeah. Yes. This is this,
this is where the, where the hope
lies and it lies in, in every area.